comme je vous le disais la semaine
dernière le clézio a déjà son nom dans
tous les dictionnaires l'important que
40 ans mais en dix sept ans il a publié
14 livres traduits dans le monde entier
et qui ont fait de lui le meilleur
écrivain français id son intelligence et
depuis n'a cessé de raconter dans une
langue simple belle que m'inspirait il
n'a cessé de raconter à la fois les
beautés et les pièges desalination du
monde moderne pour le clézio l'homme est
encombrant c'est un rapace est la
première victime de ce rapace s'est
lui-même mais ayant chacun de nous un
désir de pureté un désir d'absolu
l'enfance est un paradis perdu et nous
ne se sent de progrès de l'avoir perdu
est ce pour autant que le clézio ta
mystique en tout cas c'est un écrivain
qui fuit les micros et les caméras
et ce n'est pas un hasard si dans son
dernier roman il fait l'éloge du silence
de la soif et du désert faut-il vous
appeler jean marie gustave le clézio ou
jmg le clézio comme il est indiqué sur
la couverture de vos livres
c'est comme vous voulez jouez bien vous
m'appeliez j'aime ce club j'aime
beaucoup mon gmg occasion parce que je
trouve ça fait un peu non de voitures de
motos
j'ai une jmg le clézio sens après très
beau et comme l'a souvent parler des
voitures et c'est un nom de passeports
canon ne passe pas oui c'est à dire que
j'ai un passeport mauricien et sur mon
passeport morice a écrit jmg le clézio
on ne met pas le prénom mais les
initiales dans votre premier roman
procès verbal personnage principal qui
s'appelait dans paulo vivait dans une
villa de la côte d'azur il en sortait
rarement mes temps en temps il écrivait
sur son papier sur son paquet de
cigarettes il écrivait quelques
notations à la propose une sorte de
mémoire et un temps de journal intime un
peu bizarre vague notée à acheter à
manger papiers journaux
et puis ils n'étaient pas cette formule
faire un effort pour voir le monde
j'ai l'impression que je jour d'hui
parce que je sais que je craignais
beaucoup les caméras coup fait un petit
peu un effort pour pourvoir du monde
on pourrait être vu par le monde oui
mais c'est la même chose on vit ça c'est
un petit peu la même chose
non c'est vrai ce n'est pas que je
crains les caméras mais simplement que
je pense qu'il ne faut pas ne faut pas
trop parler ne faut pas trop s'expliquer
c'est pourquoi lorsque l'on risque de ne
pas dire exactement ce qu'on voulait
dire et on risque un petit peu de de ne
pas les tricks à d'inventer l'écriture
est bien supérieure pour ça parce que on
ne se laisse pas emporter par les mots
quand on écrit me contrôler oui mais
comment gagner des gens à l'écriture
comment faire lire
jmg le clézio si n'avons pas de temps en
temps une interview dans la presse
écrite et un entretien à la radio ou à
la télévision
enfin je pense que c'est ça passe
surtout par le par believe je crois
qu'on un écrivain est connu surtout
parce qu'il a écrit par tellement parce
qu'il fait ou parce qu'ils disent oui là
je commence cet entretien à mon avis
d'une très mauvaise façon parce que oui
je fais référence à votre premier vivre
le procès verbal que je fais est un
petit peu de la culture je sais que ça
vous agace beaucoup car
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose d'un
peu redondant sorte de duel entre vous
et moi j'ai l'impression de vous dire
vous avez écrit vivo lire mais moi je
les ai lus alors au fond je suis aussi
fort que vous et ça je sais que cela
vous agace un peu flatteur non ça ne
m'agace pas mais je pense que un
écrivain et nouveaux à chaque fois qu'il
fait un livre c'est à dire que ce n'est
pas un nouveau livre c'est un peu un
nouvel écrivain à chaque fois on est
nouveau chaque fois qu'on écrit un
nouveau lieu alors oui